[Music]
[Music]
foreign
where's your girlfriend loser where's
your girlfriend oh wait that's right
she doesn't exist just like santa i
found out recently
hey first off santa is real bro he
exists in the hearts of all who believe
and second off this
[Music]
joke's on you my penis was hot anyways
hey knock it off my office now
okay i've seen this before this whole
competition
isn't over a girl at all you're both
just trying to one-up each other
and prove you're the big man on campus
they call it
toxic masculinity forget about this
stupid fight
your friendship that's what really
matters what friendship too far
hey hey come on guys look when i was in
high school i constantly used to fight
with my best friend over a hot girl
that was actually your dad over your mom
anyway look then i just found another
girl that i really liked
and i started hooking up with her
instead
wait that was your mom anyway look what
i'm trying to say here is
girls they come and go the only thing
that really matters here
is friendship now that is forever
but you don't even talk to my dad
anymore and i know that cause my mom was
sending out christmas cards
and she goes should i someone to slater
and he goes nah
i don't talk to him anymore it would
have been nice to get one of those
got a cool collection of fridge magnets
nothing to hang
and you keep saying that none of this
matters but according to your story
it totally mattered like max dad winning
that battle was
probably one of the most important
things he ever did yeah if he didn't win
i wouldn't exist
oh my god that's true whoa so the girl
we fight over now could end up being our
future
wife when i think about it like that i
mean
i just know that pamela is not the one
for me
me they're best friends again yeah until
there's another girl we're both
attracted to
great sweet thanks coach
yeah really glad we have this talk
yeah i appreciate it me too do you feel
better i feel great
you